>> BOYD: Hello, everyone. My name is Ryan
Boyd and I'm a developer advocate working
in our Developer Relations Group. I'm with
the Google Apps Marketplace. And this is Dave
Primmer and he's an engineer in our OAuth
team. We're here today to talk about OpenID
single sign-on and OAuth data access for Google
Apps. Now, you may wonder why we're here.
There's all sorts of material about these
two topics. There's all sorts of confusion
about these two topics, of course, as well.
We're here really because we've worked with
a bunch of Marketplace partners over the last
couple of months to launch in the Google Apps
Marketplace. And there's been all sorts of
confusion about which of the flavors of OpenID
and which are the flavors of OAuth they should
be using for the different used cases and
how users are coming into their application.
So we're here to talk about that, and we're
here to try to provide you some guidance on
the different flavors and when to use them.
We're not going to be diving deep into the
protocol and showing you all the bits of an
OAuth signature or anything like that. So,
don't expect that as part of this talk. So
as long as we're prepared with that, we'll
get going. You can view live notes and questions--you
guys have already seen this stuff on many
other sessions so far, so go to Magic Wave
on Bitly and you can ask your questions. And
we'll try to leave a little bit of the time
at the end of the session for that, although
I think we're a little bit cut short on time
here because the keynote ran a little bit
late. So the agenda today; first of all, we
want to talk about terminology, then we want
to go to a little bit of history of these
protocols and then go into each of the protocols;
OpenID, OAuth and then a hybrid combination
of the two, and then talk about the Google
Apps Marketplace and then the evolution of
this SaaSy Payroll application, and then the
Q&A we talked about. So, SaaSy Payroll; SaaSy
Payroll is a fictitious app; the app doesn't
really exist and it's for handling the payroll
of small and medium-sized businesses. How
many of you went to the Marketplace session
that I did yesterday? Okay, you probably recognized
the UI. SaaSy Voice, at least, was a real
application that worked; this doesn't. But
we have a pretend company here too called
smart-lawfirm. Smart Law Firm is a company
that uses Google Apps for their business and
they use the SaaSy Payroll application. So,
we're going to be using these two things throughout
the presentation. Terminology. First of all,
we have two different main terms that we're
going to be talking about here. Authentication:
the goal of authentication is to get secure
knowledge of the identity of the user and
then we're going to talk about authorization
as well in getting appropriate access to the
user's resources; things like with Google
Apps, like Calendar, Docs, Spreadsheets and
that sort of thing. First of all, I want to
talk a little bit about the history of these
protocols. Well, first one here is back in
2005, Brad Fitzpatrick at LiveJournal invented
this thing called OpenID. And the goal was
to allow you to use your OpenID account to
login to places--other places around the Web.
And it was an open protocol so that you could
also use other accounts and other providers
to login on other places around the web. But
then, the next couple of slides here, we're
going to be talking about Google's particular
history with authentication and authorization
protocols. So, back in April of 2006, Google
launched a Calendar API. This was the first
Google data API based off of the Atom Publishing
Protocol that was being formed at the time.
And we needed a way to authenticate users
that are--and authorize their data access
for Calendar. So, if you were writing an application
that used Google Calendar and wanted to mini-play
the user's Google Calendar and get access
to their data, you needed a way to, you know,
make sure that the users who they say they
are and tell Google that information. And
so, use client login, you basically pass a
username and password over to Google. We return
the Token, you can use that Token then to
access the user's Google Calendar. Well, there's
a bit of a problem in this in that many applications
then are asking for people's usernames and
passwords. So, the AuthSub protocol was released
shortly thereafter, in about two moths afterwards,
and this really solved that challenge. It
basically allowed you, if you were a website,
instead of asking for the user's user name
and password, you would redirect them over
to Google, they would enter the username and
password on Google site and again you would
get a Token to access the user's data. Meanwhile,
you know, Google is doing these proprietary
protocols, but a lot of standards were underway
in development. We talked a little about OpenID
earlier. But the OAuth standard came out in
December 2007 that will work of a lot of people
in the community to really come up with a
standardized version of this web authorization
scheme that AuthSub was. And the idea behind
this is really just, you know, you learn this
technology once and you can use it with a
lot of different APIs across the Web. So,
the OAuth standard was launched then and Google
went about implementing it in June of 2008.
So, basically, the OAuth was the way to do
a standardized version of what AuthSub allowed
and have this Web redirect flow. Then, OpenID
launched shortly thereafter for Google consumer
accounts. If you're Gmail accounts and that
sort of thing, we launched the OpenID protocol
so that you could login with your Google consumer
account or Gmail account at many different
websites around the web as long as they were
what's called an OpenID relying party; and
we'll get into some of that terminology. And
then, OpenID for Google Apps; for those of
you here and care about Google Apps, it launched
in--last year. And then, finally, the Google
Apps Marketplace. The Google Apps Marketplace
launched just a couple of months ago and it
really just is a way that you can sell business
applications to Google Apps customers and
it uses a lot of these different technologies,
but hopefully in a more user-friendly way
and hopefully more developer-friendly way.
So, OpenID. OpenID is really for Federated
Identity; and what do I mean by Federated
Identity? Well, web applications called relying
parities accept the assertion of identity
from identity providers, such as Google and
Yahoo. So, if you want to go login to one
of these applications, whether it be Tungle,
SaaSy Payroll, Aviary, eFax, all of these
services are OpenID relying parties and you
can login to them using your Google account.
So you don't actually have to create a new
account and password on each of these sites.
What information do you get as an app developer,
though? You get essentially this URI. It's
an opaque URI and anonymous identifier, but
it's static. So, if you visit a web application
today, they get that same URI as if you visit
it six months from now. So, it allows you
to track users over time, but it is relatively
anonymous. In the case of Google Apps, it
has the Google App's domain name in it, but
it has this long string of numbers for the
user's identity. Now, there's more information
available via OpenID, and we're going to get
to that when you talk about some of the extensions
that we support. This is kind of like the
mission statement that's on the OpenID web
site: "OpenID is a safe, faster, and easier
way to login to web sites." So what do we
mean by that, safe? Well, the user only enters
their credentials in one place: on the website
or the OpenID provider. That's obvious as
to why that is safe. Faster, the user is often
logged-in to their OpenID provider and we're
going to see that shortly. So the user really
just has to authorize passing their identity
to a website. And easier, the user no longer
needs to create and maintain a bunch of different
accounts. That's obviously a lot easier. I'm
sure you're all familiar with the problem
of name space collisions while you go to create
accounts on new sites. And many of you may
reuse your passwords too, so that becomes
safe as well. Discovery is a really important
part of OpenID, though. You really need to
be able to determine the OpenID provider for
a particular user. In order to do that, there
are a couple of different processes. Let's
go into what traditional OpenID was. Traditional
OpenID, you saw a dialogue box that look like
this. It asks you to enter in your OpenID,
which was a URL, and you would enter that
in and hit sign in. Now, who actually remembered
these URLs? Geeks. Geeks were really the only
people that used this original form of OpenID
because they are the only ones that cared
to create these URLs and remembered these
URLs. So, over time, there's been a number
of different people getting together and doing
research on the user experience of OpenID.
And what they came up with was a little better
forum called the NASCAR in the community where
you present the badges of a lot of different
providers, identity providers on one single
page. So, this is the NASCAR for Tungle, and
you can login, you know, via OpenID with your
Google account or your Linkedln account or
your Yahoo account; lots of different providers
allowing you to login. But this did have one
important problem. If your provider wasn't
listed there, you couldn't login with that
provider. So, it basically was up to each
of the relying parties or each web application
to decide which badges to list there. I'm
going to actually show you an example of an
interface somewhat like this on Manymoon.
For those of you who aren't familiar with
Manymoon, Manymoon is a project management
app on Google Apps or that's well-integrated
with Google Apps. But first, I'm going to
show you logging in with my traditional Google
account. As you saw over here, I was actually
logged-in to Gmail already. So, logged-in
to my account and I hit Google here. And because
I'm already logged-in with my email account,
all I'm required to do really is say, "Yes,
I will allow this website to have access to
my identity." Fairly simple, a lot easier
than the typical process where you would create
a new username and password. So, now, Manymoon
actually has access to my name and I hit sign
up and I'm immediately into Manymoon and able
to create a project and this is a brand new
account. So, much faster, much easier than
creating a new username and password, verifying
that password, get an email verification and
all that traditional process that you're used
to on many websites around the web. So, I
tried to go to the next slide when I was in
the web browser; that didn't' work. But what
if you want to use OpenID on your own domain?
If you're a Google Apps user, you have a Google
Apps domain, or if you wanted to use a different
provider. Let's say, you wanted to use your
MySpace account to login to Tungle, in this
case, and MySpace wasn't listed there. But
you don't want to have this complicated URL
to remember. So the ideal user experience
in my opinion is something like this: the
website would ask you, "What is your email
address?" And you would enter in your email
address and hit login. Now, isn't it quite
anonymous to some of the initial versions
of OpenID? But it does create a better user
experience, in my opinion. This is actually
the ideal goal of the folks that are working
on WebFinger; it's a new up and coming protocol
that was just discussed a lot earlier this
week from my reading the notes at IAW down
in Mountain View. So, this is actively under
development, but we're not quite there yet.
Now, I want to talk a little bit here about
Google accounts versus Google Apps accounts.
You mentioned--you heard me mention earlier
consumer accounts and Gmail accounts. They're
actually distinct from Google Apps accounts.
We have two different ways that we store those
accounts. So, you may see actually on many
websites the ability to login with either
of them. You'll see a Google button and a
Google Apps button like you do here. And,
you know, we've really tried with Google Apps
to get somewhere between where we are today
and what that ideal environment is where you're
just entering your email address. So, on this
case--in this site, if you enter in or if
you--sorry--if you choose your Google Apps
account here, you'll be prompted to enter
in your email address or domain name. And
what this really does is allows OpenID Discovery
process to occur. And Discovery with Google
Apps domains occurs in two different ways.
The first way I'm showing here is traditional
OpenID Discovery where in this case the SaaSy
Payroll application is a relying party and
it goes off to smart-lawfirm.com and says,
"Hey, who is your OpenID provider?" And really,
you know, that transaction is great except
that many Google Apps customers don't actually
host their own websites. Many Google Apps
customers just want email and Calendar and
Docs and that sort of thing; you don't have
a website or don't really understand how to
setup an OpenID identity information--sorry--Discovery
information on their website, if they do have
one. So, the second way helps them. You can
check whether smart-lawfirm.com in this case
has outsourced Discovery to Google. So, for
Google Apps this is necessary. You have to
go over from a SaaSy Payroll, ask Google,
"Hey, do you know who the OpenID provider
is for the smart-lawfirm.com?" And Google
will say, "Yep, I'm the OpenID provider" and
life is golden, and users will be able to
login. Now, the format that you get for these
two different types of accounts, the format
of the OpenID you get is a little bit different.
I'm just going to show you these here, so
that you'll recognize if you're storing, you
know, people's OpenIDs in your database tables.
You recognize that, you know, consumer accounts
will be on google.com and Google Apps accounts
will be on their own domain names. Now, Google
supports a number of different extensions
for OpenID. These different extensions are
listed here. For those of you who are already
somewhat familiar with OpenID, you may recognize
some of them. I'm going to go into detail
on just two of them. And the first is Attribute
Exchange. So, remember earlier I talked about
you just get this opaque static identifier
with OpenID and it looks something like this.
You know that the user is on smart-lawfirm.com,
but you don't actually know who they are.
Well, as a web application, you want to know
more information about the user because you
can create a much better user experience.
You saw that with the Manymoon demo and it
pre-filling my name and password. So, in this
case, to get more information, use Attribute
Exchange. And Attribute Exchange with Google
at least will provide things like the first
name, last name, email address, and language
of the user. Now, Google is a, you know, a
trusted identity provider when it comes to
the email address. We will verify that the
user's email address really belongs to them.
But there are some less trusted identity providers
per se that allow users to actually set their
email address for Attribute Exchange or set
their name and that sort of thing. So, you
want to actually whitelist the trusted identity
providers and you may want to take a little
bit of caution on the Attribute Exchange attributes
with the other identity provider. So, more
information about this is actually on code.google.com
in our Best Practices section and, you know,
this is really helpful to remember because,
you know, you want to make sure that your
application is securely using the email address.
Some applications that really, really, really
want to be sure about that email address,
you still go through that nor--the, you know,
typical verification process where it sends
an email off to the user and then ask them
to login with OpenID. But how is all of this
done in practice? You've heard me mention
a number of different complicated terms, perhaps.
You heard me talk about Attribute Exchange,
you heard me talk about relying party. It's
not really hard in practice because there
are a bunch of different libraries out there
for you to use. I'm not going to go suggest
that each of you handwrites their own OpenID
code. First of all, it can be a little bit
complicated from the security aspects of it
and likely you'll mess up. Not that I don't
trust all you development skills, but everyone
messes up when they try to go implement these
sort of protocols and you don't want to mess
up when it's something, you know, as important
as securing the identity of your users. So,
there's all these libraries out there. These
libraries, you know, have been used by the
community and evaluated by the community,
so you want to check them out. Now, I mentioned
there's those two flavors of OpenID in the
Discovery proc--or for Google. And the Discovery
process works a little bit different for the
Google accounts, Gmail accounts versus Google
Apps accounts; all of these libraries supports
Google Apps accounts in that Discovery process;
some natively and some with some extensions
that are listed there that are available on
code.google.com. All right. Now, Dave is going
to come up here and talk about OAuth data
access and getting access to Google Data APIs
using OAuth for authorization.
>> PRIMMER: Thanks, Ryan. Okay, so OAuth.
I just want to reiterate some of the things
that Ryan said in the beginning that I'm going
to be basically covering high level used cases
for OAuth and helping you decide what scenarios
you're going to--in which scenarios you're
going to actually choose a specific type of
OAuth or authorization. And I'm not going
to into like the details of all the bugaboos
around request signing and things like that,
but as Ryan also said, client leverage are
your friends here, so. The most important
part of understanding OAuth is getting a good
understanding of the roles involved because
it is an access control system. So, I want
to go over some terminology to begin with.
First, we have your standard blue cylinder.
This is a protected resource; it's a Calendar
in this case. And the protected resource actually
belongs to a resource owner. The resource
owner is the person who approves access to
the protected resource. And the protected
resource resides on a server and--oh, I wanted
to back up really quickly and say that the
resource owner is actually an interesting
role because it could be an individual, in
which case the protected resource would be
just a calendar--as an individual's calendar--or
it could actually be an organization, a company
like the Google Apps organization. And in
that case, the protected resource would be
all of the calendars in that organization.
So, we have the server and the server receives
an HTTP request form the client. And the client,
in this case, is a client in the sense of
an HTTP client. SaaSy Payroll, the application
that Ryan mentioned, might actually be a server
on the internet itself taking requests from
end-users. But in the concepts of OAuth, it's
basically a client because it's making a request.
So, if you learned about OAuth prior to this
year, you probably encountered some different
terms. I'm gong to try to actually update
your understanding of the terminology in this
presentation; I'm going to use the new terms.
Pre 2009, the term consumer was used instead
of client. Service provider has sort of broken
out into server and protected resource now.
And user is actually resource owner and sometimes
user. And for more information on why these
terms changed and more explanations of the
terminology, you should probably check out
the Authoritative Guide to OAuth 1.0. It's
written by the author of the spec. And I also
wanted to point out that the RFC that was
just actually published in April has a pretty
good explanation to terminology and it's a
pretty readable document, so I recommend that.
So, here are the two main components of OAuth
that I'm going to be talking about today.
Key management, which is the way that a client
and a server establish trust and access control.
And access control can actually be done for
an individual or for a whole group of users
in a Google Apps domain. And thus, this basically
breaks down to three concrete steps. There's
client registration, where the developer goes
to the server and does some key management,
registers itself. There's a resource owner
grant; this has to happen before any resources
can be accessed and then the actual access
of the resource by the client application.
So, here, we have our SaaSy Payroll app again.
And SaaSy Payroll actually has a cool feature
that it allows the users to actually add their
payroll dates to their Google Calendar. So,
it needs to write to the Google Calendar in
order to do this. And it needs to actually
get the user's permission in order to write
to the Google Calendar. But before I show
you that access approval step, I wanted to
kind of basically explain what the developer
of the application like SaaSy Payroll has
to do in order to do that key management to
establish that trust. So, step one is actually
for the developer. It's getting an OAuth Key
and Secret. And this step is similar to a
step you would do as a developer on any Cloud
app--Cloud platform, such as Amazon, they
have a developer key; Yahoo, NetFlicks and
so on. So, this is the screen actually at
Google that you would see once you had approved--once
you had proved ownership of the saasyapp.com
domain. You can see the--I have the OAuth
consumer Key and Secret circled here. These
are the credentials that the client uses to
identify itself to the server when it makes
an OAuth request. So, the developer gets these
credentials and uses them in their application.
So, step two--and so, that's step one, which
is key management--and step two is access
control. Now, this is actually done by the
resource owner; different party and at a different
time. But there are two types of access control
specifically in the context of Google Apps.
And I want to break that out because that
can be sometimes confusing. Much of the documentation
and introductions you'll see to OAuth cover
purely the consumer used case. It was the
original used case for the OAuth design. But
since then, actually, a lot of the popularity
of OAuth has been around using it in a business
context. So, the key difference here is whether
or not the user is the resource owner. So,
the resource owner in the case of an individual
is the user itself that would be using the
application. But when it's a company, the
resource owner is actually the domain administrator
or the person who's in charge of all the data
for the domain. They actually--essentially
own all of the accounts in the domain. And
the users still use the applications and they
can control their data and they can also control
data access, but there's also another party
that's actually making decisions on their
behalf. So, this is how it splits out; two-legged
OAuth and three-legged OAuth. Three-legged
OAuth is for the individual use case and two-legged
OAuth is for the business. And here's how
it works in terms of authorization. Authorization
for three-legged OAuth is done using a browser
redirect where users add a browser, actually
getting prompted to approve access. And two-legged
OAuth is more of an out of band operation
where the request is pre-authorized by an
apps administrator, and the user is not prompted
when they choose to access the resources.
So, let me show you how an approval might
be done in an apps domain context. And later,
Ryan's going to actually show you the Marketplace
flow which, if you're a developer for the
apps Marketplace, you'll see as preferable
to this one. But this sort of breaks out the
concrete details of the access control decision
that are--that is done by the apps administrator.
So, here we have the Google Apps control panel.
And this is a screen where you can actually
create a new grant for a specific application.
Here we already have SaaSy Voice at the bottom
that has access to Docs in context and we
have fields that actually allow us to create
a new grant. At the top, we have the resource
owner; it's the administrator, smart-lawfirm
and we have fields for the client and the
protected resource. So, the administrator
would actually fill this out and enter in
the consumer key that we saw in the previous
step that the developer did. And here, I have
the Calendar--the Calendar APIs, the protected
resource. When you authorize that, it becomes
another one of the access control entries
for the domain. So, from her on out, SaaSy
App can actually access the Calendar for all
the users in that company. So, that's step
two, access control. And step three is actually
when the developer chooses to access the resources.
This might be when the user actually uses
their application or it could be, you know,
even when the user is not around. So, I'm
going to give you a demo of a two-legged OAuth
cURL and this is basically just a teaching
aid to try to show you how the protocol works
from a--from a wire protocol standpoint. So,
I've written a little cURL application using
the Google Data APIs client libraries and
this application has just a few parameters.
And when I execute it, it should give me a
listing of the parameters for this two-legged
OAuth call. So, this is essentially doing--if
you use cURL, it's got a URL that you're--that
it's accessing. It's got the HTTP method which
is a get. And in this case, I've also included
another parameter, which is ryan@smart-lawfirm.com.
This is the user that we'd like to access
the Calendar resources for. As you can see,
the Calendar URL does not have user context
in it, so it actually gets this from the user
parameter. And then the final two are the
consumer key and consumer secret--I'll highlight
them here. So, the consumer key and the consumer
secret are those credentials that the developer
obtained and that the administrator authorized
in the second step. So, let me show you what
happens when this actually is sent in an HTTP
request. I have here the actually raw HTTP
request and the beginnings of the response.
And the thing that makes this OAuth, makes
it different than just a regular HTTP request
is the authorization header. Oops. See, here.
This is what--this is the--basically the header
that my client library had created with the
parameters that I provided it. And you can
see there it specified the consumer key, there's
notes, time stamps, signature--I'm not going
to go into details of all--how these things
are generated or what they mean, but that
is essentially the information that the server
receives. It allows it to validate the credentials
of the client and trust that the response
was created by someone who they know. So,
the response, as you can see, that comes back
from the calendar server or--I'm sorry, in
this case the contact server is the Atom XML
representation of Ryan's contacts. So that's
a really simple HTTP request and that's what
really OAuth is. So, what did we just see?
We saw an authenticated HTTP request where
the client has essentially a role account,
name, and password; that's the consumer key
and consumer secret. In addition, there's
another parameter which is the OAuth requester
ID, ryan@smart-lawfirm.com. This is a Google
specific parameter. It allows the Google Calendar
server to know whose Calendar that they need
to access. And, essentially, is some of the
request attributes are bundled up and signed
in a standard way. That's what the OAuth specifications
tells you how to do, which is the signing.
So, why would you want to use two-legged OAuth?
Well, the most important reason is you don't
want to actually prompt the users for their
approval. This is common in enterprise software
scenario where you'd provision an application
for an entire set of users and, you know,
once you've installed it for them they shouldn't
have to, you know, click through more prompts
saying, "Yes, yes, yes, I want to use this."
It's also appropriate for server to server
communication. There's no browser needed.
It works for essentially web services authentication
to do batch processing or background tasks.
And the main trust relationship is that the
resource owners tells the server via an ACL
to trust the client and this ACL is usually
stored server side and there's no Token involved
to transmit the credentials. So, now, let
me show you the other style of authorization,
three-legged OAuth it--which is three-legged
OAuth. And this is the one that you're probably
more familiar with, the one that you've seen
demoed repeatedly. In three-legged OAuth,
basically, what we have is a delegation by
an individual to a client. And it's basically
the process where the user's browser is redirected
to a server. The user says, "Yes, I'll allow
this to happen." And in the process, the Token
is actually transmitted to the client that
essentially encodes those--that permission
grant. And here, I've showed you--I've shown
you that--what an OAuth Token essentially
looks like. This would be in the authorization
header that we saw earlier. It's encoding
essentially the permission grant: "Joe gives
the SaaSy Payroll client permission to write
to Joe's Google Calendar." In three-legged
OAuth, in the last step where the access--where
the resources were accessed is basically a
two-legged OAuth call plus this Token. So,
here's our SaaSy app Payroll again and let
me show you briefly what this looks like to
the end-user. You could see here this is the
link at the bottom where the user would click
to actually approve the access to the Google
Calendar. When they click that, they're redirected
to the Google server and you can see here
are three actors again: the resource owner,
which in this case is ryan@smart-lawfirm;
the client, saasyapp.com; and the protected
resource, the Calendar. When they grant access
to this, they are sent back to the SaaSy App
Payroll application and it's writing entries
into their Calendar. So, why would you want
to use three-legged OAuth? Well, it's appropriate
for the case where the individual is actually
granting access to the resources. It's also
interesting because the user's identity can
remain opaque. The user's identity is encoded
into the Access Token and the client never
actually has to know the identity of the user.
And, again, the user is the resource owner
and trust the client with an access Token.
So, that's pretty much what I wanted to cover
today. But before I go, let me briefly give
you an overview of what's coming in the future
and that would be OAuth2. And you might be
asking, "Well, OAuth1 is pretty young, why
would we already be doing OAuth2?" Well, some
of the reasons are that the authors of OAuth1
wanted to make OAuth an IETF standard. So,
they started the process of standardizing
it. And in the meantime, a bunch of new used
cases were codified in a protocol named OAuth
Wrap. OAuth Wrap is a departure form OAuth1
that actually requires a significant change
to the protocol. So, they wanted to increment
the number and Wrap then got folded into the
process of IETF standardization. And what
Wrap actually allows you to do is avoid a
lot of the request signing that you need to
do with OAuth 1.0. So, Facebook already has
a working OAuth2 prototype, Microsoft and
Google have working Wrap prototypes. Google
intends to support OAuth2. It's not quite
ready yet. It's almost there, but they're
still working on a few--a few edge cases and
it's being debated right now in the IETF mailing
list. And if you go to that link at the bottom
of the slide, you can actually read the current
spec to get a sense of the direction of OAuth2.
I think you'll find that it's going to be
easier to implement. You'll have to rely less
on client libraries in order to get it right.
So, now, I want to send it back to Ryan, whose
going to actually show you how you can use
OpenID and OAuth together to make you users
experience even more seamless.
>> BOYD: Thanks, Dave. All right. So, as he
mentioned I want to talk about how you can
use both of these together. As you can imagine,
there are many times that you want to get
access to the user's identity and you want
to get access to the user's data. And you
don't want to have to do these in two separate
steps. This is what the Hybrid OpenID and
OAuth protocol is all about. So, we could
see here in the case of smart-lawfirm.com
and SaaSy App. So, SaaSy App is actually asking
for some information form my account. You
saw earlier the email address. It was asking
for my email address, it was asking for my
name. But now, you can see in addition to
asking for my email address, it's also asking--sorry--for
access to my Google Calendar; and it's a one
step grant here. And after that grant is given,
the application not only has access to my
identity, but it also has access to write
to my Google Calendar. Now, the Google Apps
Marketplace. It sounded like only a couple
of you actually went to the earlier sessions
on the Google Apps Marketplace, so I'll give
you a really brief intro. Basically, it's
a place for you as developers to go and sell
your applications to businesses. These are
business-focused applications that you want
to sell in a Marketplace format. And so, when
you go and you list your application on the
Google Apps Marketplace, you end up creating
a page that looks something like this. This
is the SaaSy Payroll application as listed
on the Marketplace. And it's basically a place
that Google Apps domain administrators can
come and purchase your applications and then
they're managing kind of a standardized fashion
for Google Apps customers. So, all the Cloud
applications for--that a company needs to
run their business are all available in one
place. When you do that, then as a developer
you create this listing page. And as an administrator,
you can click that "add it now" button to
immediately install the application on your
Google Apps domain. Now, what does this mean?
Well, users is probably what you care about;
it's what we care the most about. And this
really makes it a lot easier for users to
access your applications. So, many users,
including myself, unfortunately spend most
of our day sitting in email. Email is kind
of the center of the business universe and
you want to be able to access all your Cloud
applications right from within your email.
So, that's what we've done with these Marketplace
applications. At the top of email, Calendar,
and Docs and all the other Google Apps, you'll
see this more menu, once you install an application,
and then you can access the application directly
from that more menu. It's really simple. And
once we click on that SaaSy Payroll in the
more menu, we're immediately into the SaaSy
Payroll Application. We're not prompted as
a user to grant access to our identity or
grant access to our data. This is all done
by the domain administrator at the time that
they install the application. So, there's
none of this. There's none of this. And it
makes it really a much better user experience.
Now, how does the main administrator grant
the access? Well, you can see this screen
here is the second step during the install
flow of a Marketplace application. And there,
the SaaSy Payroll application--actually, the
SaaSy Voice application--I forgot to swap
out the screen shot--but is asking for access
to a particular set of data; in this case,
the user provisioning APIs, so a list of all
the users on the domain; in this case also
the Google Docs API and the Contacts API.
And the application developer actually has
a chance to tell the administrator why they're
asking for that data too. So, the administrator
can make an informed decision on behalf of
the whole organization. But then, you're probably
wondering, "Well, how do I, as an app developer,
access this data? Once the administrators
installed the application and made the data
available for me, how do I access it?" Well,
Dave talked to you about two-legged OAuth
and here is actually, instead of registering
a domain name and getting a consumer Key and
Secret, as a Marketplace developer, when you
create your Marketplace listing, you actually
have an option here at the bottom that says,
"View OAuth consumer key." And when you do
that, you get a consumer Key and Secret for
your application. And that consumer Key and
Secret can then be used to access all of the
data that was granted to you by domain administrators.
So, as an application, you can then use that
consumer Key and Secret to identify your application
and access the data for each of the users
on the domains which have installed the app
and the domain administrators have granted
access; much simpler. And now, I just kind
of want to go through like a summary of the
different protocols that we've talked about
today before going into our SaaSy Payroll
kind of mysterious timeline here. So, summary
of the protocols. Client login was the original
protocol we talked about with Google Calendar.
You don't want to use this for new applications.
You don't want to get the user's username
and password. AuthSub was kind of the precursor
at Google at least to the OAuth protocol.
You don't really want to use that for new
applications. Then, you have three-legged
OAuth, which you use that to get access for
individual user's data. And the user--the
individual user is the resource owner and
they're authorizing access to that data. Two-legged
OAuth, you want to get access to a whole company's
data or domain's data; you can use two-legged
OAuth to do that, and the administrator is
granting the access. And then, we'll go back
to the first section of this presentation
on identity OpenID. Vanilla OpenID, you can
use to get access to a user's identity and
with Attribute Exchange information, their
name and email address. And that can be used
as Vanilla OpenID for Gmail accounts. For
Google Apps accounts, you have to do OpenID
with the Google Apps Discovery extensions,
and again, there's libraries available for
that that provides the identity of Google
Apps users. And then, finally, the OpenID
and OAuth Hybrid that I talked about allows
users visiting your web application directly
to provide access to their identity and their
data all in one step. And this really allows
you to onboard new users much faster than
you would be able to with these other protocols.
Now, I really want to show you the evolution
of how all these technologies take place in
this fictitious app, SaaSy Payroll. So, back
when SaaSy Payroll has existed for a long
period of time and they have a users table
in their database that looks something like
this. There's an email address and then there's
a password, hopefully it's a hash of a password,
and they have that information stored in their
database. And every user that comes to the
application needs to create an account. And
we'll actually show you that user experience
here with a quick video. So, I, as a new user
go to the SaaSy Payroll application, I say,
"I don't have an account. I want to create
one. Fill in my name, fill in my email address,
fill in a password, make a quick typo, correct
it, hit sign in." And then, told, I need to
confirm my account and I hop over to email,
click on a link--and this is a little bit
sped up over normal but--I'm then logged in
and can see my payroll information. So, then,
the SaaSy Payroll application, you know, all
along has been trying to figure out different
ways to provide access to the data about when
users get paid. Their customers have really
been requesting that they use Google Calendar
and they want access to their upcoming payroll
dates on their Google Calendar, so that they--it's
a lot easier for them to find out when they're
going to get paid. So, when Google launched
the Google Calendar API and then launched
after that the AuthSub protocol for authorization,
they implemented this. And their users table
and their database basically stores that Token
that they get from AuthSub. And this Token
allows them to access the user's Google Calendar
and input--or update their Calendar with their
next upcoming payroll days. And here is the
user experience for that.
So, they're in the SaaSy Payroll application
already, they've already logged-in, they click
a button that says, "Add dates to your Google
Calendar," they go to the AuthSub page and
they grant access to their Calendar and now
their payroll dates are added to their Calendar.
And you can see here we go over to Gmail and
go to Calendar and you can see the payroll
dates. You know a much more helpful way of
knowing when your upcoming pay dates are than
actually going into your payroll application
to find out that information. So, now, you
know, they've had a lot of Google customers,
a lot of Google Apps customers and they didn't
want to have to create new accounts in order
to access the SaaSy Payroll application. They
didn't want to have to come up with a new
password; they don't want to confirm that
email that we talked about. So, when Google
launched OpenID for Google Apps, they said,
"We want to take advantage of that. We want
to allow users to login with their existing
accounts. So, their users table and their
database had to grow a little bit to store
these OpenIDs. So, we can see Jane at google.com
has an OpenID in this table and does not have
a password because SaaSy Payroll doesn't need
to know Jane's password because SaaSy Payroll
can rely upon Google to assert that identity.
So, they store the OpenID, these users still
has granted access to their Calendar, so they
again have that AuthSub Token there. And here's
the user experience for that. So, on the front
page of the SaaSy Payroll they can login with
their account, they enter in their email address
or their Google Apps account. It parts across
the domain name and then they grant access
to SaaSy Voice to have access to their identity.
And now, their information is pre-filled.
Their name and their email address is already
there and they never had to create a new username
and password. Again, we'll go through the
AuthSub flow where you click and grant access
to Calendar. And now, not only does SaaSy
Payroll have access to their identity but
also access to their Google Calendar to display
the upcoming payroll dates. Now, you saw there's
two separate access grants. The first access
grant was the user granting access to the
SaaSy Payroll application to know their identity,
to know who they are. The second access grant
was them granting access to their Google Calendar.
Well, we want to combine these together. And
we talked about the Hybrid OpenID and OAuth
protocol. So, the SaaSy Payroll folks when
we release that, implemented that protocol--but
there's one key difference here because previously
they were getting access to users data via
AuthSub; now, they're getting access to the
users data via OAuth. It's a little bit of
a different protocol and has a little more
information. So, we could see the changes
to our database table here. We added a type
column to indicate the type of the Token that
we have, whether it is an AuthSub Token or
a three-legged OAuth Token, and then we added
a secret column, which is necessary for three-legged
OAuth. Because three-legged OAuth in addition
to having a Token has a Token secret. So,
we need to store that information. And, again,
I want to show you the user experience for
this flow of the Hybrid on-boarding. Again,
it's much more improved over the previous
flow. We go in and we login with our account.
And now, you can see like, you know, we saw
in previous screenshots we're being accessed
for the Calendar and their identity. So, we're
in SaaSy Payroll, it knows my identity, and
it already is having dates added to your Google
account. There is no need for that second
grant to happen by the end-user. Of course,
then in March of this year we launched the
Google Apps Marketplace. And the Google Apps
Marketplace is a place for businesses to buy
applications for the entire company. Well,
instead of having individual users coming
into the SaaSy Payroll application in small
bunches, they can now buy the SaaSy Payroll
application for the entire company of a lot
of users at once. So, in this case here, you
see that a number of users are added to the
database table. Each of them have their OpenID
because they've logged into the application
and we have this type column here. The type
column here has one additional value that
we haven't seen before and it's two LOs. So,
these users are actually having--sorry--their
data access has been granted by their domain
administrator when they installed the application.
So, we know that's a two-legged OAuth requester
then since, you know, Dave talked about that.
And for the two-legged OAuth request, in addition
to the three-legged OAuth request, the SaaSy
Payroll application needs to identify itself.
It needs to say, you know, "Here's my consumer
key" and, you know, "I have my consumer secret
and I'm identifying myself to Google." And
I'm then able to access these users all without
having a Token or a Token secret. I don't
need to have those for individual users because
the domain administrator has granted access
on my behalf. Now, I should stay here--say
here you want to store that consumer Key and
Secret securely somewhere. Your database table
isn't the right place for it here especially
because it's not different for any of these
users and you want to store it securely on
your server somewhere else. So, I'll show
you what the user experience is for the Google
Apps Marketplace, again, much more improved
for the individual end-users. So, first of
all, we'll show the domain administrator experience.
They click the "add it now" button and they
say, "I'm smart-lawfirm.com," they hit install
and they go in and they grant the terms of
service, which is a very simple terms of service.
They grant access to the Calendar data in
this case--and I forgot to use extra cell
on this mock--sorry. And then, they enable
the application. The admin at smart-lawfirm
enables the application for the entire company.
Now, let's show what each individual end user
experiences. They go into their email where
they are every day and they click on the universal
navigation link for the SaaSy Payroll application.
And once they click on that, they are immediately
into the SaaSy Payroll application. It knows
who they are. They haven't had to, you know,
grant access specifically because their administrator
has done that. And you can also see that the
dates are already being added to their Calendar.
All of these happened without the individual
end user having to do the grants because the
domain administrator is the resource owner
and has granted access for that. So, you can
see here in the evolution of SaaSy Payroll
application how much easier it has gotten
for end users and how much easier its gotten
for domain administrators to not have to deal
with the questions from the end users as to
what, you know, data they can grant access
to and that sort of thing. The administrator
owns the data. They can decide what access
to grant and then it's a much easier process.
So, improved user experience, much easier
on-boarding for users, access is granted by
the appropriate resource owners. And then,
with the Marketplace, for those of you who
don't know, you have access to over two million
businesses that are running Google Apps. There
are 25 million users in those businesses.
We're adding about 3,000 new businesses every
day to Google Apps, so it's a great place
to list and sell your Web application. There
is one little hazard to this as you saw with
the user table, you know, expanding over and
over again is that there is multiple code
pass. User and developer are probably a little
concerned about this. You have different ways
to get access to a user data and to get access
to their identity and you get multiple code
pass. Well, sometimes we, developers, just
kind of have to deal with those sort of things
in order to make the user experience much
better. So, resources. I want to give you
a list of some resources that you can use
to follow-up on some of these things. The
first resource here is for the Google Apps
Marketplace. If you're not familiar with it,
that's kind of some technical documentation
and business documentation on the Google Apps
Marketplace. And then, we use some technical
docs on Google Apps, on OpenID and OAuth.
And then, finally, something we didn't actually
get a chance to talk with you about today;
the OAuth playground. So, Dave demoed using
two-legged OAuth and using his command line
application to perform two-legged OAuth request.
There's a great tool out there called the
OAuth playground that does similar things
for three-legged OAuth and it's all a web-based
tool. You guys should check that out. And
now, we're going to go into our question and
answer period. And as a reminder, you can
go to bit.ly/magicwave to ask any questions
you might have. And we're going to be switching
our projector over here to this other computer
with the questions.
>> PRIMMER: Yeah, go ahead.
>> BOYD: I'll let you take the first one here,
Dave.
>> PRIMMER: All right. So, the first question
is about the Google Apps control panel and
if there's any way to actually control OAuth
Tokens from the control panel for expiration
and so on. So, the question here is about
whether or not there's administrator control
over the individual user grants in an apps
domain. So, a Google Apps user can still do
the three-legged OAuth dance as Ryan showed
you. They're not restricted to just using
two-legged OAuths just because they're in
a Google Apps domain. So, they could have
actually Tokens that have been granted to
client application. So, the question is whether
or not an apps administrator can actually
control those Tokens. And currently, they
cannot do that in the control panel. It's
a great suggestion and we would--we would
love to be able to provide this sort of capability.
One of the things that we've--one of the piece
of feedback we've got from administrators
when we first showed them the Marketplace
is that they'd actually like to be able to
possibly turn off three-legged OAuth grants
for all of their users globally, so they could
only be the--they could be the only ones that
are actually granting access to their users
and the users couldn't actually grant by themselves.
>> BOYD: So, I'll take the next one then.
>> PRIMMER: Oh, all right. Good.
>> BOYD: What about OAuth, OAuth-ing the Android
phones? There is--you could definitely, as
an application developer for Android, use
OAuth for getting access to user's data from
an Android device. Actually, we did a session
at Google I/O last year, which is the Mobile
Social or something like that. You can look
it up on YouTube. And as part of that, I actually
wrote an Android app that opened up OAuth
in a web browser allowed granting access.
The trick here is you need a URL or in the
version of OAuth that I used at the time you
need a URL to redirect back to once the access
was granted in the web browser. The nice thing
about Android is they actually allow you to
register protocol handlers. So, I registered
a particular protocol that went back into
my application with that Token. There is a
new version of OAuth that allows you to do
both desktop applications, mobile applications
and also things like, you know, embedded devices
and all where you don't require that redirect.
So, you can explore using that as well. And
why don't we take the question that's in the
audience here?
>> I have two questions. One is about the
OpenID libraries that you mentioned in the
screens. Could you comment anything on the
Python Libraries if there's any?
>> BOYD: Sure. I can comment, but it's not
going to be a comment that you like.
>> That's okay.
>> BOYD: The, you know, we listed a number
of different libraries there for many languages.
Python was noticeably excluded. There is a
Python Library for OpenID if you're trying
the Vanilla OpenID accounts. No one has ridden
the Google Apps Discovery extensions for that
Python Library yet. It's a JanRain Library,
very similar to the PHP and Ruby Libraries,
but my understanding is it's not quite as
extensible.
>> Okay.
>> BOYD: So, if you want to take that on,
go for it. I mentioned about not writing your
OpenID code.
>> Sure.
>> BOYD: Feel free to ping us and let us know
if you do write that, though, and we're happy
to do a little bit of review on it and then
get some other people to review it because
there is obviously security concerns there.
But, no, I'm not aware of a Python Library
right now that supports the Google Apps extensions.
I did mention the word JanRain there. JanRain
also does commercial products called RPX and
there are some other providers that have commercial
products for these sort of things too. They
provide very simple rest APIs to perform OpenID
and they do have libraries available in Python.
>> Okay. The second question was related to
OAuth and Google Data clients and the APIs.
There's some confusion there as to OAuth not
retrieving data for all the APIs, so you need
particular version of G Data clients. Is that
thing going to be sorted out or...?
>> BOYD: So, I mean, I think like a lot of
our documentation unfortunately still refers
to both client login and AuthSub. We need
to update our documentation. The perfect place
for us to do that--and when I say documentation
I also mean the client libraries that we support.
And the prefect time for us to do that is
when this OAuth Wrap comes out because OAuth
Wrap makes the protocol a lot easier both
to explain and also to implement, and it basically
goes down to not having signatures anymore
and then it operates very similarly to the
AuthSub protocol. So, I think at that time
we'll be going through and update it. But
if you're particular libraries or whatever
come see me afterwards and we'll talk about
them; there may be ways to do it. I think
internally we've done some samples and all
that use a lot of these libraries that aren't
quite published yet, but we're going to be,
you know, coming out with those soon.
>> Thank you.
>> BOYD: Thanks. So, we'll take one more question
from moderator before we jump into the question
from the audience. Are there any plans to
support OAuth for GTalk protocol, XMPP and
the GTalk client? The short answer is, no,
there are no direct plans. We did actually
extend OAuth Support to iMap and SMTP to,
you know, native protocols for email communication.
And, you know, so I can see that it's quite
possible that we would extend it for XMPP,
but we don't have any direct plans right now.
Thanks. Go ahead.
>> So, it looks like a server has to maintain
a secret, you know, if you're running a server
you have to do that server side. So, what
can you tell us about how Google maintains
their secrets and how they--well, any recommendations
they would have for how customers to, you
know, keep the secret secret both in the general
case and maybe for AppEngine.
>> PRIMMER: Yeah, so, the key management that
I demoed was Symantec key HMac secrets. So,
that means you have a secret essentially on
the client somewhere and one on the server,
and both are needed in order to make a request.
At Google, we actually store secrets in an
internal system that is heavily guarded and
it actually is available to a number of our
servers so that we actually can centralize
the key management, allows us to look up keys
and verify them based on the--how the client
identifies themselves. You can find some examples
of this actually in the Shindig Libraries,
I think. They have some built in key management
systems for OAuth because there actually is
an OAuth proxy built into the Shindig product
that allows it to actually make--act as a
client and make out that request and accepting
coming requests. And then as far as the client
goes, the client actually is a really important
thing to remember. Basically, we demoed HMac
secrets that are stored on the client. But
in this case, we're not talking about installed
software clients that reside on a person's
computer. We're talking about hosted applications
where a company is actually in charge of the
secrets and they're protected on their servers.
For the case of an installed client and embedded
client or something like that, you don't actually
want to use HMac because it can trivially
be hacked and your secret can actually be
exposed. As--If you're an application developer
and you store your consumer Key and Secret
in an application you distribute to your users,
as soon as that's hacked, every single one
of the companies that has been granted access
to that key can then--has now had their data
exposed through you. So, it's an extremely
important password to protect.
>> BOYD: Okay. Did that answer your question?
>> But if I'm run--but if I'm running a service
on Google App Engine...
>> PRIMMER: Yup.
>> ...and I want to play with this and it
looks like I'm going to have to keep a secret.
>> PRIMMER: Well, actually there's a couple
of options there. You can just act as if App
Engine is a pure hosting platform and do all
of the OAuth stuff that you would normally
do on your own third party server, but AppEngine
actually has the ability to make request and
use the OAuth proxy that I mentioned earlier.
>> Okay.
>> PRIMMER: So, you could actually just identify
your application. It knows who you are because
you're running on Google software. It finds
the keys that it needs in order to sign your
request and signs on your behalf and manages
the keys for you.
>> Okay. That's great. Thanks.
>> PRIMMER: All right.
>> BOYD: Okay, I'll take the next question
here, interested in knowing the current security
concerns with OpenID. There aren't too many
of them. I don't know if you guys recently
saw the U.S. government actually started accepting
OpenIDs in some of their websites and there
was a lot of work that was done in order to
validate the security of OpenID in that process.
Of course, this, you know, it still depends
on who the identity provider is and what OpenID
request they're approving and how they're
improving it. So, for Google, we actually
support one extension that you probably saw
on the slide earlier called Pick PAPE, the
Provider Auth Policy Extension that actually
allows you, as an app developer, to make things
a little bit more secure. And, basically,
what this means is in the case of that payroll
application, for instance, you want to make
sure that the user is still behind the keyboard
when the user goes to login. They didn't walk
away from their desk and their co-worker is
trying to evilly look up their payroll or
something like that. And so, you can do that
by basically adding it at PAPE request to
say, "Hey, I want to make sure that this user
has actually logged-in recently. And if not,
prompt the user to login again." And Google
will actually do that prompting on behalf
of the application to make it a little bit
more secure. And so, there are plenty of other
things that are going on, but that's the one
thing I'd give as an advice on terms of security.
Next thing was about OAuth integration to
the Android SDK. There's no plans that I'm
aware of, but you guys can certainly follow
up with the Android team about that. They
would probably be the most knowledgeable.
>> PRIMMER: Yeah, you've been waiting. Go
ahead.
>> BOYD: What's that?
>> I'm thinking of some...
>> BOYD: Oh, sorry, I didn't see you there.
>> ...environments where the user doesn't
have good control of the browser or if the
desktop like a kiosk, how do you deal with
OpenID sign out in those situations?
>> BOYD: That's a good question. Everyone
keeps asking us about that especially with
regards to Marketplace applications. It's
kind of having single sign out for OpenID.
There's no real such protocol yet. It's something
that I'd definitely like to see happen in
the standards community, coming up with a
good protocol for OpenID and single sign on.
And then, I'd love to see it's implemented.
But there's no real good use there. At this
point, the user would have to sign out of
their Google account in addition to signing
out of any applications that they've logged-in
to.
>> Do you see Google maybe driving some of
those? Proposing some standards?
>> BOYD: Chris is turning is head and looking
to the back of the room. I could see that
happening, yes, how's that? I don't have any
specific information on it, but it is something
that, you know, we've been begging for internally
to some of the engineers that are more involved
in the standards process. And so, I hope that
we do that. And I'll take that as another
vote for that to happen. Let me answer one
more question here form...
>> PRIMMER: We have one more live.
>> BOYD: You can ask the live.
>> PRIMMER: Yeah, I'll go for the live one.
>> BOYD: Go for it.
>> PRIMMER: Go ahead.
>> All right. So, we have Google installed
at our college and so we have 3,000 or so
users. I like the idea of installing the App
within the user interface. Is there a way
to restrict that to subgroups? Because we
have students, staff and faculty and we want
to have applications running just for subgroups
within that that are only visible there.
>> BOYD: Not at this point. When you install
an app from the Marketplace, it is available
to everyone in the domain. A lot of the applications
that are on the Marketplace do actually provide
interfaces in that application to restrict
access to it. So, for instance, the concur
expense reporting product prompts you during
the install process, "Would you like to allow
anyone in?" or "Would you like to allow a
named list of users in?" And they allow you
to select from users in your domain that you'd
allow--you want to allow access to. This is
something we're definitely interested in doing
for the Marketplace to restrict it at our
level, but definitely we'll look at whatever
application that you're looking at and see
if they have a way to do it. Right now, it
would still be in the navigation for everyone
in the company, but some of those applications
might do restrictions.
>> Thanks.
>> BOYD: Thanks. So, the next question here
on moderator has a little bit of a messed
up problem with some URL encoding here, but
I'll try to read in between the percent 20s.
Can you also cover App Engines, create federate
login URL, documented or not--it is not documented
except in the Java Docs? This seems like the
optimal way for Google Apps integration in
App Engine. So, basically, we're definitely
looking at ways to make the App Engine process
easier. This is one of the reasons that our
team hasn't sat down and written that Python
code that someone was asking for earlier because
we're trying--you know, most of the requests
we've gotten from Python are actually from
App Engine users and we're trying to concentrate
our energies in making it a lot easier in
App Engine. So, you guys saw it already in
the Java Docs, you should see something, you
know, more formal out there that makes this
process of OpenID much easier. And actually,
there's a comment on here right Google.
>> CHAN: Hey, Ryan. So--hi everybody. I'm
Wesley Chan. I work in developer relations
for the AppEngine team. And there is no equivalent
create federated login URL. However, the create
login URL function or method has the ability
for you to pass in a federated identity. So,
we don't have two functions. One is, you know,
wants the Vanilla, one wants a federated one.
They're both combined together into one, single
method. If you have any other questions, just
come find me afterwards.
>> BOYD: Okay, so just going through the moderator
thing if there's not any--oh, there's an in
person question here if you want to go?
>> Yeah, so, I'm--I just want to understand
the questions about Android from other people.
So, you mentioned that the OAuth is not provided
in SDK, right? And you also mentioned that
they're on the libraries possible. So, can
you talk about which one you would recommend
and--for accessing Google as well as, maybe,
Facebook or anything like that?
>> BOYD: I mean, so, the work that I had done
was with three-legged OAuth inside of mobile
device. So, it would actually open up the
web browser from the application and the user
would grant access in the web browser and
then be redirected back to the web application
using one of those registered protocol handlers.
That is able to be done with the Java OAuth
Libraries, just kind of out of the box. So,
you can do that with the Java OAuth Libraries.
And I was doing it at the time with Open Social,
so you could access, you know, users' social
graph and that sort of thing. I'm not actually
sure with regards to Facebook what libraries
are available for that, but you can definitely
use OAuth. I mean, they support--Facebook
now supports OAuth2, but I just really haven't
dived into what are the libraries that I've
used before with Android. We'll work with
that. If I have my OpenID provider, can I
use the directory to authenticate to my Google
Apps? Well, you can actually use your directory
to authenticate to Google Apps. And that brings
up another usage of the word "single sign
on" in some of our Docs. Google is actually--can
be a SAML relying party. SAML is a protocol
for doing single sign-on. In this case, it's
happening in the other direction. So, you,
as a company, have something that runs on
your servers that basically looks at your
directory and manages the authentication of
users. And Google just relies upon you to
assert the identity of your users. And so,
yes, you can use your internal directory.
It gets a little complicated again because
the term is both using a single sign-on in
our documentation. If you are installing an
application from the Marketplace, your next
best question is probably, "Can you use that
application still even though that you're
users are coming from the directory?" And,
yes, you can. So, the application will rely
upon Google to assert the identity of the
user and then Google in turn will rely upon
the Google Apps identity--or SAML provider
to then assert the identity to Google and
it does this whole big round trip. But you
can ask me in office hours or out in the SandBox
or after this session if you have any--more,
you know, you need any more details on that.
I think our best kiss hands on implementation
example. Well, we have some Hello World examples
for the Marketplace that handled the two-legged
OAuth scenario and the OpenID scenario pretty
well, in a fairly simplistic fashion for PHP
and Java. There is another application which
you saw me accidentally show up in the screen
here of SaaSy Voice, which we wrote for another
session, which is a little bit more expanded
example, but an example of a real web application
that we're looking to open source after I/O,
after we get a little bit of sleep. Do you
have any other ideas, Dave?
>> PRIMMER: Well, I think that there's a--there's
a library that we just--or an application
we just released as a tool to investigate
the Buzz API; it's called Oracle, which works
with any OAuth-enabled end point. That's actually
a fairly small set of codes. I think it's
probably only a couple of hundred lines of
code, if you look at the whole thing to get
a sense of how it's doing it. And it's actually
doing three-legged OAuth. In addition to that,
I would say if you really wan to keep it simple,
just focus on the two-legged OAuth the used
case just to understand exactly what is going
on in a two-legged OAuth request. And don't
get caught up in like the Token here, Token
there, you know?
>> BOYD: Yeah.
>> PRIMMER: All the--the whole dance because
that can actually get kind of confusing. There
is quite a few HTTP requests and redirects
involved in OAuth--in three-legged OAuth.
And if you just concentrate on two-legged
and learn that, that's sort of the basics.
>> BOYD: Definitely.
>> PRIMMER: And...
>> BOYD: And then, jump over to that OAuth
playground when you go to try to figure out
three-legged OAuth.
>> PRIMMER: Yeah.
>> BOYD: That explains a lot of that process
and how it works once you have a little bit
of knowledge about the keys and secrets and
so forth.
>> PRIMMER: Right.
>> BOYD: I think we need to stop questions
here actually because we're running a little
bit close to the time when the next presenters
need to come up. But thank you very much for
coming by. And feel free to ask us any questions
you have in the SandBox or... Thanks.